[Music]
is anybody uh anybody one familiar with
challenges that are going around on like
tick tock and stuff like that no
i've seen the break the school challenge
you ever seen that one what where like
kids will go into like their high school
bathroom or some [ __ ] and they'll just
rip doors off or like like jump up and
like pull lights down he's cracking up
about this i watch it and i'm like this
is terrible like our kids are [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up like a [ __ ] zoo bro
yeah it looks i'd be so pissed if i
worked at the school yeah
and then you watch that stuff even as a
student you're like this is why we can't
have nice things like this is why i
can't show you i feel like that's why we
didn't have doors that's why we didn't
have doors in the [ __ ] our bathroom
we took a [ __ ] without doors no for rest
or even as a first grader you get paper
towel right you're sucked with water
yeah i did that
oh
i forgot about that all recessed lawn
you had all those paper towels stuck on
the [ __ ] mop wow that was science
though in a way yeah yeah
that's hella science well there's this
challenge on tick tock going around
right now called the blackout challenge
does anybody hear this oh it's just like
they hold their breath and [ __ ] or they
or they like choke you out and you like
yeah exactly now i remember when i was a
kid i remember doing semi-similar stuff
like during like pe or during recess and
stuff like that you would like go up to
like a [ __ ] wall and you're put your
arms here and your homie would like push
against your chest or something like
that why are you trying to make your
arms raise up yeah yeah stuff like that
but then you would i remember kids would
actually pass out i remember or like
fall to the ground like hit their head
oh my god you did yeah my friend was
like we're like we're sleeping over and
he's like oh you guys want to feel what
it feels like to like pass out like yeah
yeah i prevented late so much
for like like 100 like count to 100
wherever and you stand up and they push
you and then you're like
oh [ __ ] and then they're like waking you
up like did you feel that you just
[ __ ] passed oh so cool
i always pretended
ironically that's exactly how it went
down right i think that's exactly how it
goes down i never passed out from it
because i always had to fight fake it
because i was like man it's not working
well if you're waiting to be cool you're
trying hard i was just like [ __ ] my
whole life i faked every single one of
them i gamed the game
did you want to get you in a rear naked
and you didn't have i i never i never
passed out from every anything like they
could make that happen right now yep
nick will teach you nickel teach you how
to pass out dude yeah honestly i've been
passed out a couple times
i know how to do that [ __ ] he's a pro at
that and when you wake up like
you feel like you have the best snap of
your life really yeah you're just like i
don't know about that man that's how i
felt
i've been oh i've been put out way more
than you dude are you sure yeah way
because i suck really bad oh dude way
more bad
wow all right so tick tock right now is
being sued after two young girls died
while trying to recreate a viral trend
called the blackout challenge how'd it
die it got choked out that sounds like
not even pretty bad
two the lawsuits allege that lalani
erica walton eight years old
ariani jailene arroyo nine years old
died after copying the trend in which
participants tried to choke themselves
into unconsciousness but how did this
like what's the mechanics behind it
today are they just doing this [ __ ] yeah
or did they hang themselves did they die
together
so a royal from milwaukee was found
quote hanging from the family's dog's
leash oh it's like basement that's not
even the challenge yeah she was taken to
a hospital and put on a ventilator but
had lost all brain function and was
eventually taken off it's not even the
challenge that's [ __ ] death dude
people said you did it wrong
that's just the [ __ ] hanging dude use
that court similarly walton from texas
was found quote hanging from her bed
with a rope around also they didn't do
this together it was separating my god
man so bart is the ultimate asian dad
dude yeah departs like
you [ __ ] up all that they just had
better work ethic that's not the game
but then so
they
they did it separately but they had the
same idea of like yeah i think it just
happened at the same time so two
different lawsuits are going on wrongful
death lawsuits were filed this past
friday in la
um and yeah so just two kids were just
found hanging and police took walton's
phone number uh phone and tablet and
later told her stepmother that she had
been watching blackout challenge videos
on repeat
um
royal was taken to the hospital but her
brain cells were already messed up and
they're not the first children to die
while allegedly trying to participate in
the challenge nyla anderson 10 years old
similarly died while trying to copy the
choking challenge leading to her mother
filing a lawsuit against tick-tock and
his parent company bite dance in may
the challenge has been linked to at
least four other deaths of children
ranging from 10 to 14 in australia italy
colorado and oklahoma
um this is how i know i'm closer to
being an old man than being a kid
because my first thought is why can't
they just do nice
challenges whatever happened the good
old
good old cinnamon challenge
let's feed the homeless
did someone die did somebody die for the
cinnamon challenge more of a challenge
actually why wouldn't that go viral huh
make yourself pass out doesn't really uh
seem like a challenge feeding the
homeless chicken and stars i will say
there is one challenge
i will say there's one challenge going
around right now it'd be really funny if
we recreated it this is the blackout
challenge no it's the tortilla challenge
oh it's worse oh
you put water in your mouth you play
rock paper scissors and everybody holds
a tortilla in their hand and if you lose
rock paper scissors you get slapped in
the face with the tortilla and obviously
whoever busts up for spits of water out
it's actually pretty [ __ ] funny
i can't breathe out of my nose so let's
turn into the blackout challenge which
is exactly why you're the number one
candidate for that challenge should we
do it
he blacks out with the water spill in
his mouth
because i can't breathe on my nose dude
hold on
yeah don't do it right now do it right
now close your mouth breathe i can do
out of one nostril that's what i'm
saying one of them works yeah right now
sometimes just hold water in your mouth
right now put some water in your mouth
right now for like the rest of the video
how do you breathe at night
oh yeah that dude put some water in your
mouth put some water hold it yeah
and then breathe through your nose full
no that's that's not a slap that's a
very nice love tap wait living oh [ __ ]
we're losing them
nick wake up nick um
fresh ones that are that are sitting out
for a sec they get hard dude yeah yeah
oh what if you toast them first
corn versus flour
this is why jk party always has to take
it to the next level dude corn tortilla
is crazy but it's just taking the whole
[ __ ] tortilla like package that has
50 of them
or you get the bottom of a sope man [ __ ]
you yeah
challenge dude
unless it's soggy then you then you're
good
bart just turns into a whole pizza
challenge inside the box you're gonna do
a bun me challenge or you just slap your
face with a bomb specifically mr
baguette where it's hella tough oh that
would be tough do people forget that
they did stupid [ __ ] too as a kid
everyone does because like that blackout
challenge [ __ ] existed since when we
were kids too well yeah but we missed
the window because i remember they were
doing the [ __ ] challenge i was like
how did i miss this [ __ ] window i
never got a shot you're like i wanted to
give so many [ __ ] yeah i don't want
to suck all those dicks
wearing different colored lipsticks or
how [ __ ] up is this you think about
how many people did things like the
blackout challenge back in the day but
it just wasn't recorded yeah so there's
like still hell of death and they really
died yeah it's just a living room
imagine all the other imagine all the
sad kids that like killed themselves are
like actually just part of the blackout
challenge and we're just but we didn't
record it so they're like oh no it was
just so sad we just thought it was
suicide yeah
we didn't need blackout challenges we
were doing [ __ ] wrestlemania
finishing moves
[Laughter]
but did you record it
no we didn't have any cameras see that's
why it's not as viral i like super kick
my friend in the face
like you know like sweet chin music i
remember in the locker room i was in
middle school my buddy was like do the
rock bottom to me and i was like all
right dude the rock bottom is like you
grab somebody you pretty much slam them
and he's like do it on the bench and he
was like this small korean boy and he
was like [ __ ] i remember the story
about this kid is that when he was in
the seventh grade he had a ride in a car
seat because he was so underweight oh
like that's how small he was that's
right yeah dude that's gotta be a
[ __ ] exaggeration that some of the
[ __ ] bully-ass kids made up
the car seat kid
he's like that's my little brother he
already went to school he gets dropped
off first
like you know you're in the car seat
you're the car seat kid
and i rock bottomed him on my [ __ ]
bench and you split him in two and he
wanted destroyed it yeah did he sell it
though yeah
he was really hurt i was like oh no oh
yeah he's like
you gotta breathe and [ __ ] dude
dude he was terrible
i know dude it was crazy my favorite
[ __ ] is somebody taking the stunner and
they're just flopping around like a fish
after
they're
every time the rock takes the stutter
he's like [ __ ] flying around 30 feet
dude it's so good yo have you guys seen
santana jackson
he's a michael jackson wrestler yeah
that guy
he he gets somebody into ddt and then
does the moonwalk yeah the second drug
yeah
check this [ __ ] out real quick so he's
just doing michael jackson yeah his
character is michael jackson
he wrestles as a
is that tommy dreamer bro
dude he's like a [ __ ] jacked michael
jackson
yo check this [ __ ] out dude
[Music]
damn that looks just like mike oh
straight to the dick oh he fights unfair
that's how you know he's a [ __ ]
villain right there
everyone hates this guy
oh yeah
come back bro this is sick i'm a fan oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the other guy was walking
that's so sick
[Music]
[Music]